yeah welcome to this video playing Dark
Knight MF 11 probably ok so i have not
played this guy before and the king's
indian y'all but I'm we have what am I
going to play the classical or what can
I try can try the Petrosian system maybe
I haven't played this for a while oh I
get bit 9 a-6 / chosen holed up in a 55
so yeah okay probably just castling and
creamy 8 yeah this kind of lines are
interesting like delaying some things
and wonder can I go Bishop everyone
probably I'm not really familiar that
much with with those with those lines I
came here I'm shutting down the center
with the Queen only eight and everything
I don't know if this is such a great
setup it's close to a throw a decline if
not a theoretical line yeah here Bishop
f3 is a threat so I think I should go
back to kay let's kick that one away and
develop this so um how is black ago wow
really it takes his sex and d6 he's got
compensation yeah right ok that's this
press ok and that's all c21 what I'm
irritated I'm irritated him I mean it's
counter attacking the pawn on e4 but
still I have a hard time ok let's take
him that took me too much time after all
I was probably going to take anyway and
so I should have done that quicker so um
2692 it's no good but I can push him
back and then check on d6 I really don't
think
this should be good you can take a form
it hmm ok rocky I'm going to take anyway
so what is happening here he's taking
you for ok I have to take that and
what's now his pieces seem a little bit
uncoordinated but maybe I'm not seeing
it correctly hmm da-dum ok so let's just
get this into the game
controlling 28 okay so well here I mean
I can take play Bishop to b6 which
probably is not bad hmm ok I cannot take
e 5 anyway I have to speed up otherwise
the position is not going to matter at
all due to my time time problems um b3
huh maybe be 397 two is six could happen
okay I'm going to go to be six just
controlling the aid and limiting that
night is going to play a 4 of course and
this is what made me hesitate a little
bit it's a bit bit of a shame that he's
allowed to hamp on my queen side okay
okay maybe that's better actually in
comparison for him so let's just push
the pawns and hope that they're not
going to be a weakness by the strength
where to we're going where to go I
probably just back attending a b5 here
b5 now as a threat b3 Bishop e3 route 27
would be quite good I think he has to
react to that I think wow this is
interesting what is the point hmm ok ok
one is going to go E 4 yeah probably
just activate that rook
before and then he wants to go Bishop b5
huh huh that is the point and probably
so just be five here i'm not sure i have
to speed up cannot really take lots of
time to find the trying to find the
absolute best moves yeah okay I've
Knight f6 or Bishop c4 probably Bishop
c4 the c-4 is hanging huh okay that's
bad that was bad okay now he's
controlling this one Bishop b5 might be
an idea so maybe here to check b7 my
rook is pinned down you one that's a bit
unfortunate time warning him the thing
is that with the time situation it will
be difficult anyway from me make we've
taken root B seven for a total equality
but I'm down and quite a bit of time
if you move the bishop now and might
have rook c8 for Bishop age six and
winning so he cannot just go to to ne ne
square and the Bishop f5 i'm going to
take b7 with the bishop yeah that's a
nice position but one minute something
down okay so I'm checking this so can I
can I keep can I keep the B pawn that's
the question here
Bishop c6 just covering it really
covering it reliably still 44 seconds is
not it not a very comfortable situation
ok so I'm going to play rook be eight
probably and then be six if possible
I care I'm going to take this and push
me six so this is a very very safe
situation for okay is going on yes gotta
check prevent we should be five school
and like here and look to be seven
coming my roots are pretty active
yeah it's catching up a [ __ ] timewise
that's good
he really has no defense whatsoever Ruby
seven we can cover it with ever look at
phi about some move but it's not really
helping him very much okay nice got that
that didn't help how do I actually
promote now maybe like b7 here b7 rook
e8 or something who know now is doubling
here ah that was silly very silly ah
shoot I'm just getting that back what a
shame cuz I I cannot follow fine Madras
I know he doesn't want it check I know
nah check okay I'm just too rusty after
that time it's after that after that
break ah I mean it was totally crazy to
have declined the draw I mean I mean I
thought I was up on time this is why I'm
saying it was crazy I'm sorry like one
second but I mean I really I haven't I
haven't moved the mouse even there for
hot for a couple of weeks when I was
away I was only using a notebook a
little bit here and there but not yet
not played a single game of online chess
for more than a month so yeah okay what
can you say about all that um yeah
around here and that looks kind of
comfortable but it only got really bad
later I mean here this is the engine is
giving equal which is it's still pretty
active so it shouldn't
be that bad ok 2 p.m. ok the computer
prefers Knight f6 pretty much right
surprising ok so I computer wants to do
this yeah this is more precise yes I
understand now now I've got a temple
here under on the bishop it's a bit
better than this is the same structure
but I'm just a tempo up in essence ok so
here here I'm just winning right yeah
plus 1 point something I'm winning the
bee pollen and visit the game yeah okay
I knew it would be difficult for me
because of my my rustiness so how to how
to do this here time-wise I'm equal now
but I say I didn't have I didn't really
have the the proper IDM and here this
was this was i educate I just have
Bishop before he of course ok that's not
an easy win to say because this is hmm
I'm not sure how easy that is actually
maybe it is easier because I can't get a
route to f5 like this this f5 and then
on the seventh day it's probably open
but I didn't even I didn't even see that
Bishop before esposo I was just too
nervous him after that break the idea is
just equal of course yeah okay that's
not it's not meaning anything here yeah
okay so yeah it was a bit of a
unnecessary loss but I have to get back
and stride I didn't even play any warm
up games I just wanted to play some some
serious game so just start it right over
the bed ok I hope you enjoy it anyway
thanks for watching